اذا في المقاييس الميدانيه كان بجعبات
كتائب القسام اليوم مفاجاه وقعت ثقيله على
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي رشقه كبيره من
الصواريخ تنطلق من قطاع غزه وتصيب الداخل
الاسرائيلي طبعا اهميه هذه الصواريخ انها
تسقط الى حد كبير وتضعف الروايه
الاسرائيليه التي تقول ان كتائب القسام قد
ضعفت القدره الميدانيه التي تمتلكها
وتفككت القيادات او تفكك الربط بين
القيادات وبين العناصر الميدانيه اذا
مجموعه رشقه كبيره من الصواريخ اطلقتها
كتائب القسام واصابت تل ابيب وايضا
المناطق المحيطه بمدينه تل ابيب او التي
تعرف بتل ابيب الكبرى وصلت ايضا الى ريشون
لتسيون وهناك صواريخ الى الرمله طبعا
القبه الحديديه مقلاع داوود قالت ال
القوات الاسرائيليه انها تمكنت من اسقاط
عدد كبير من هذه الصواريخ وانها لم تصب
الاماكن التي استهدفتها ولكن لفت ان مطار
بن جوريون الاساسي في اسرائيل توقف عن
العمل نتيجه هذه الرشق من الصواريخ ثم
تلتها بعد اقل من ساعتين رشقه اخرى الاولى
قالت القسام انها مهدات الى الشهداء في
الضفه الغربيه والثانيه قالت ردا على
استهداف المدنيين المستمر في قطاع غزه في
هذه الاثناء وبينما كانت هذه الصواريخ
تنطلق وتصيب المدن والبلدات والمستوطنات
الاسرائيليه في الداخل كانت المعارك
مستمره في قطاع غزه سنبدا من الشمال ايضا
هناك المزيد من المفاجات نحن نتحدث عن
اماكن اشتباك تقريبا ما زالت على حالها
منذ بدء التوغل الاسرائيلي في قطاع غزه
نحن نتحدث عن استمرار الاشتباكات في
الشجاعيه الشجاعيه حتى الان كما يبدو
القوات الاسرائيليه لم تتوغل الى كاملها
اي لم تنهي المسافه داخل الشجاعيه ولم تصل
بعد الى قلب مدينه غزه القديمه ايضا كان
هناك اشتباك واستهداف في حي الشيخ ضوان
استهدفت ناقله جند
وجيب هامر دخل وتوغل الى داخل حي الشيخ
رضوان استهدفته كتائب القسام واوقعت
اصابات وهناك ايضا اشتباكات في تل الزعتر
هنا عندما نتحدث عن تل الزعتر كانت
اسرائيل قالت انها سيطرت على بيت حنون
واشتباكات في جنوب غزه قبل وبالتوازي مع
ذلك ايضا كانت الاشتباكات مستمره في خان
يونس خان يونس ما زالت بؤره اشتباكات
قاسيه بالنسبه للطرفين استهدفت فيها ايضا
كتائب القسام مجموعه من الجنود واوقعت
قتلى وجرحه والاستهداف الذي حدث
ايضا كان في الشمال وفي الجنوب بفترات
متفاوته لكن ما لفت اليوم هو على الجبهه
الشماليه
الاسرائيليه تقريبا
في
منطقه كريات شموه كريات شموه هي واحده من
المستوطنات المحاذيه للحدود مع لبنان
اليوم
استهدفت صواريخ مطار كريات شموه وهو مطار
مدني الاذاعه الاسرائيليه قالت ان 18
صاروخا انطلقت باتجاه مطار كريات شموه
كتائب عز الدين القسام قالت انها استهدفت
المطار بنحو 12
صاروخا